Im zentrum unserer galaxie der milchstraße gibt es ein extrem mysteriöses objekt es ist eine ungewöhnliche
unglaublich große materie ansammlung die wahrscheinlich irgendwie mit dem supermassereichen schwarzen loch
im zentrum unserer galaxie
Zu tun hat könnte es ein kosmischer string sein ein extrem massereiches objekt in form eines
Superdünnen fadens jetzt ist es erstmals gelungen ein hochauflösendes foto zu machen
Ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und bekommen es jetzt in 26 werken mit allen fakten
Zu dem mysteriösen objekt und was es sein könnte und wie es vielleicht auch mal wieder die dunkle materie in frage stellen könnte herzlich willkommen
Der astronom farhat josef sade aus chicago war es der die ungewöhnliche materie ansammlung. Im zentrum der milchstraße
2016 entdeckt hatte ein filament so werden große
zusammenhängende strukturen
Im universum genannt fiel um ist lateinisch und bedeutet faden und diese materie ansammlung sind tatsächlich aus
Fadenförmigen verbindung aufgebaut es ist wohl
2,3 licht jahre lang und krümmt sich um das schwarze loch namen sagittarius
Stern im zentrum der galaxie mit hilfe einer neuen methode konnte jetzt erstmals ein wirklich
hochauflösendes bild von diesem objekt gemacht werden zitat das foto zeigt uns das parlament aus den schwarzen loch entstehen muss
So einer der beteiligten forscher mark morris von der university of california doch wie ist es konkret entstanden
Darüber gibt es bereits drei theorien der ersten idee nach könnte das filament durch
Superschnelle teilchen verursacht werden diese werden wohl aus dem schwarzen loch geschleudert doch wenn gas ins schwarze loch gerät kann ein
vertikales magnetisches feld in zylinder form entstehen dass roth irrt in diesem
so entstandenen zylinder
produzieren die beschleunigten teilchen strahlung dabei denen sie sich um die magnetischen feldlinien und entfernen sich vom schwarzen loch
Dieses szenario würde für astronomie teams die erkenntnis bedeuten dass das magnetische feld in solch einer umgebung nicht chaotisch sondern
Gleichmäßig ist eine beeindruckende erkennen die zweite theorie ist gleich noch
Mate spannender denn bei dem parlament könnte es sich auch
Um einen kosmischen string handeln also ein extrem dünnes objekt mit masse und elektrischer ladung bisher
Ist das aber ein theoretisches konstrukt ein string konnte bisher noch nicht entdeckt werden
Doch in der theoretischen physik nimmt
man an dass solche kosmischen strings existieren und sich in richtung eines galaktischen
Zentrums bewegen sobald er sich dem er eigenes horizont nähert könnte es also dieser string vom schwarzen loch verschlungen werden
Falls sie sich also tatsächlich um einen string handelt wäre dass die allererste
Entdeckung eines drinks überhaupt wow ein solcher string ist ein absolut wahnsinniges objekt es hätte einen durchmesser der es nahezu
eindimensional macht der trillion sste teil des kleinsten atoms das wir kennen des wasserstoffatoms und sein gewicht wäre
exorbitant bei einer länge von sechs kilometern
Würde ein solches zwingen so viel wiegen wie die erde bei einer länge aber von 2,3
Lichtjahren wären es rund
4,7 millionen sonnenmassen
moment 4,7 millionen sonnenmassen das ist ja sogar mehr und jetzt 8 und festhalten als unser zentrales schwarzes loch
gitarrist stern haben soll nämlich vier millionen sonnenmassen
Soll die masse dort sein das ist wirklich ziemlich verrückt und ich erinnere mich mehr wieder daran dass die teilchen der dunklen materie immer noch
Nicht gefunden wurden und solche extremen massen natürlich auch wieder dazu beitragen die fehlende masse vielleicht doch woanders, zu finden
Wahnsinn ja und der dritten theorie zufolge könnte die anordnung und die position des filaments zu dem schwarzen loch auch ein
Kosmischer zufall sein demnach würde es keinen zusammenhang geben dann wäre es also nur ein
filament wie jedes andere in der galaxie doch seien wir mal ehrlich sage ich ein zufall der soll wirklich eher
Unwahrscheinlich ich finde das alles unglaublich spannend nehmen wir nur mal an das von
den zentralen löchern in den galaxien solche filamente ausgehen als solche
kosmischen singstar
Aufzugehen das wäre für mich echt wieder ein indiz dafür dass die bisherige theorie von der dunklen materie die eine ist die noch nicht
bestätigt wurde tatsächlich ein irrtum schon sehr spannend und
Diese kosmische springs das ist auch nochmal spannend die könnten tatsächlich etwas mit der stringtheorie zu tun haben 2002 wurden sie nämlich
Theoretisch vorhergesagt, im rahmen der stringtheorie. Am ende der entstehung unserer vier raumzeit dimension würden sie im intergalaktischen
Maßstab entstehen weil das ist wirklich irrsinnig jetzt bin ich wirklich gespannt auf weitere erkenntnisse dazu
gewonnen werden können denn der theorie nach müsste dieser string
gravitationswellen ausstrahlen und er müsste die hintergrundstrahlung verzerren die entdeckung dieses filaments jedenfalls spannend
forschungsteams weltweit auf die folter dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
Junhui, zu aus cambridge ein teil des nervenkitzels der wissenschaft ist über einen terium
Zu stolpern das nicht leicht zu lösen ist wir haben keine antwort noch der weg dorthin ist
Fasziniert ja wenn er also nicht verpassen wollte vielleicht wie vielleicht schon bald die theorie der dunklen materie umgeschmissen wird
dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp bahn schon bald
wird es da nämlich hier ein video geben und ihr erfahrt dann auch vor allen anderen von diesem video vorab
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum mitmachen und themen vorschlagen zb
Und ja das ist der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo mit der
genau vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken dunkle materie rätsel lösen spielen schwarze löcher
eine rolle ja ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran